she's fun gorgeous and super talented
which can make her seem too perfect to
be true but just like us stuff Cameron
is no stranger to embarrassing moments
watch until the end to find out which
moment still makes dub cringe with
embarrassment dub scoop by the time dub
Cameron was a tween she knew she was
meant for something big so her family
made the decision to move to Los Angeles
California when she was 14
despite being bullied by her classmates
for the majority of her life Dov clung
to the things that made sense to her
singing and acting and she hasn't looked
back at the haters since doves rise to
fame was quick and Steve she began
starring in plays in 2007 and by 2013
she had her own show on the Family
Channel Liv and Maddie quickly became a
fan favorite however her most successful
role has been the one of mal from The
Descendants franchise dove has been in
the spotlight for a long time so she's
bound to have a handful of embarrassing
moments Dan moment Meryl let's start off
with a fangirl moment yes that's right
Ethan dove Cameron can get starstruck
during an interview with the 17 dubbed
about her experience at the Golden
Globes just when the actress was about
to step onto the red carpet she was held
back by her team it turns out that the
one and only Meryl Streep was standing
directly in front of dub she immediately
began gawking over the oscar-winning
actress which didn't make for some
pretty pictures so doves crew got her to
stand back and wait until Meryl was a
bit further down the carpet before
allowing the star to make her own grand
debut dad fuel to the fire dove took out
her phone and don't be acclaimed actress
while making some peculiar noises I
think I made a noise somewhere along the
lines of like wood we've got another
starstruck moment lined up for you so
keep watching descendants we couldn't
imagine anyone else but Dove filling in
mouths jewel encrusted boots The
Descendants franchise is jam-packed with
hectic choreography and challenging
vocals so dove tends to get in the zone
during her filming sessions dove came
clean about her most embarrassing
descendents moment and the start
couldn't help but laugh while telling
the story while filming the song if only
in the woods dub was secretly ambushed
by the cast director Kenyatta
got the cows too surprised of in the
middle of the forest and since she
wasn't expecting it she thought she was
about to be attacked by a large animal
she was in the woods after all after
hearing the loud noises coming from
behind her the actress fell off the log
she was standing on convinced that
something big and angry was coming for
her the moment was captured on film
which made it all the more embarrassing
effort noises as many of you know dove
Cameron plays the role of Gwen Stacy in
the marvel rising franchise although
she's used to being on the small screen
she's no stranger when it comes to voice
acting and although she loves portraying
Gwen she's not a fan of effort noises
during an interview with 17 dub
mentioned that voice acting can be super
embarrassing this is because you're made
to work alone in a sound studio while
tons of people stare at you Dov went on
to say that effort noises are the
hardest and most uncomfortable de master
not familiar with this term well who
better to explain it to you then dub
herself but it's things like huh or
things like that who wouldn't be
embarrassed to do those noises over and
over again in front of a crowd of
professionals fan moment Alicia we
promised you another fangirl moment and
here it is Dov has always been a fan of
actress Alicia Silverstone who is best
known for playing cher in the 1995 film
clueless and since dubbed play Sharon
clueless the musical she couldn't
believe her eyes when Alicia came to
watch the show and say hello according
to dev she was so starstruck she had a
nervous breakdown
which was super inconvenient to make
matters worse the moment was caught on
camera
despite her squeals of happiness and
extreme theon girl moment dove is happy
to have met her idol super awkward first
kiss one of Deb's cringy its moments
revolves around her cloud9 co-star Luke
then word while auditioning for their
roles Dave and Ben were asked to kiss so
that the directors could see if they had
chemistry
however Doug was just 17 at the time and
completely caught off guard on top of
that dub was super shy and terrified of
kissing someone in front of a crowd of
people so when someone offered her a
stick of gum
Doug immediately accepted unfortunately
the person had been joking which only
furthered her embarrassment according to
DA the
kiss was awful but apparently Disney
Channel directors saw the chemistry they
wanted because both Ben and Dev landed
their roles off for date dance going on
an awkward date is a rite of passage to
adulthood so we're not surprised that
dove has an uncomfortable dating story
according to the actress she went on a
date with a guy she didn't even know
during her early teenage years she
accepted to go out with him since he was
friends with her friends however she
didn't know anything about him convinced
that he invited her out of pity
dove kept her distance from him
throughout the entire evening her date
hardly paid her any attention so she
accepted the fact that she had been
asked to the dance out of sympathy well
it turns out dub was completely wrong
because well her date eventually came up
to her and grabbed her hand at that
moment she realized she was the one
giving him the cold shoulder and she was
instantly overcome with embarrassment on
stage Crump dove has had her fair share
of awkward moments but according to her
this one is the most embarrassing one
she's ever encountered it happened when
she was 8 years old and she still
remembers it to this day so it's bound
to be a bad one during a performance in
her hometown theatres dove ended up
krumping and laughing midway through the
show she'd done the show so many times
that she'd become a little too
comfortable on stage so when she spotted
her friend behind the curtain she got
lost in the moment during a flash freeze
number dove began krumping and laughing
with her buddy who was safe and sound
behind the curtain
however dove broke her character in
front of the entire crowd coincidentally
that was the night that a big reviewer
was set to critique the production and
he made sure to give dove a shout-out in
his review yikes
so which embarrassing dove moment was
your favorite let us know in the
comments section below and that's a wrap
thanks for watching the things give this
video a big thumbs up if you love dove
Cameron and don't forget to hit that
subscribe button we'll catch you next
time
[Music]